the maga love affair with elon musk
seems to be coming to a sort of
predictable end
um this all sort of got going around the
twitter purchase that was simply not to
be
uh elon musk
of tesla and spacex fame announced that
he wanted to buy twitter and that he had
reached a deal with twitter i didn't
believe it for a second i didn't think
he was going to buy twitter then uh sort
of like nothing moved forward for a
little bit and uh elon musk announced
that he's having some concerns about the
number of bots on the platform this was
after a whole flood of right-wing users
came back to twitter following
right-wing accounts on the heels of elon
musk's announcement musk started to say
well
i'm not really getting the data i want
about the number of fake users and bots
so i'm putting the purchase on hold and
i said at that point he was never going
to buy twitter and he's not going to buy
twitter and now elon musk actually says
that he's backing out and it's of course
not at all surprising but in addition to
this donald trump and elon musk are now
publicly feuding in the sense that trump
appears to be lying again and elon musk
seems to be telling the truth now i
think a lot of this was inevitable in
the sense that
elon musk is basically a self-centered
opportunist as are many tech ceos i
don't necessarily say that uh
pejoratively although it could certainly
be interpreted as such and um as a
result he and donald trump are now not
getting along well during his rally in
anchorage alaska um donald trump
said the or actually you know that's the
wrong order first and foremost um donald
trump at his anchorage rally
said elon musk told me that he voted for
me
but later said i've never voted for a
republican and so therefore he must be a
liar elon musk responded to a report of
that on twitter by saying it's not true
meaning it's not true i ever told trump
i voted for him so trump getting called
out for one apparent lie
then at the anchorage rally trump going
uh on a rampage
attacking elon musk who he also referred
to as leon musk during the rally
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i call that
one right
leon's i tell you what
elon
elon
is not gonna buy twitter no where did
you hear that before
from me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
no he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying
not going to be buying it
although he might later who the hell
knows what's going to happen he's got a
pretty rotten contract i looked at his
contract not a good contract right
okay so breitbart highlighting that clip
and then elon musk responded i don't
hate the man but it's time for trump to
hang up his hat and sail into the sunset
democrats should also call off the
attack don't make it so that trump's
only way to survive is to regain the
presidency so the love affair between
the maga people and elon musk
predictably predictably sun setting i
think we could say now let's talk a
little bit about elon musk i get a lot
of people in my audience who are elon
musk fanboys they love them they love
his products they love everything
um and then i hear from people who
absolutely hate elon musk and they see
him as some right wing extremist and all
these different things
i
it might not surprise you that much uh
the same way that i don't really care
about or fall into the cult of
personality among politicians i i you
know i was a bernie supporter i wasn't
part of the the bernie cult so to speak
there's the tulsi cult andrew yang had a
cult around him donald trump
i just see these as people
hopefully they do more good than harm
and if i think that they're the best
option i'll vote for them but beyond
that i don't really get too sucked into
the personalities of it and also in
having met a lot of these people they're
just normal people i mean think about
all the flaws everyone you personally
know has they're just normal people
because they're normal people all of
these other people are as well and much
the same way
on a business level
if you bet against elon musk it doesn't
seem to be the best bet
elon musk has had a number of really
successful businesses i've disclosed i
bet on that
when in 2015 i bought tesla stock and
the stock went crazy although now it's
down from its peak and whatever okay
okay
it seemed that that was going to be a
business that would grow
and it's by far the largest electric
vehicle manufacturer now in the united
states great the the the degree to which
tesla has advanced
the electric vehicle development and
normalization
uh is incredible and the reason that
every other
vehicle manufacturer now is scrambling
to get more electric vehicles out there
uh is because of the success of tesla
that's a great thing
elon musk also is just wacky on a lot of
political stuff the the the recent
tweets about
uh the the right is where it's always
been but the left has become extreme
that's just wrong that's wacky i don't
know who gave him that idea just wrong
um his recent thing about i'm now going
to vote for republicans i'm only voting
for republicans republicans are better
for this that or the other reason he's
just wrong it's wacky it's completely
wacky disagree with it completely
but at its core
the interpretation that makes the most
sense to me is elon musk has some bad
ideas and some good ideas he uses tax
law to his advantage as all of these
rich guys do he is a self-centered
opportunist who at the end of the day
wants what's best for himself and for
his companies it's not a big surprise we
don't have to deify or demonize and just
recognize it for what it is and all of
that being said
he has never struck me as a particularly
reactionary guy i think he's gotten
sucked into right-wing republican
politics maybe it's hanging around with
rogan i i don't know what it is
but it seemed as though the love affair
between the maga people and elon musk
was destined to end and it seems that it
is indeed now ending so hopefully we can
close the chapter on that i don't
believe he ever intended to buy twitter
and i don't think he's ever going to buy
it
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the u.s
i've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why i now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and i can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name or it takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below